Utiliza el método de completar el cuadrado perfecto para que la siguiente ecuación
cuadrática "y" igual a -3x cuadrada más 24x -27
tenga una forma canónica y además identifica el vértice. Y bueno nosotros ya sabemos que es una forma canónica,
cuando tenemos una ecuación cuadrática en forma canónica se ve de la siguiente manera "y" es igual a ax -"b"
elevado al cuadrado y a esta expresión le sumamos "c", esta es la forma canónica de una ecuación
cuadrática, y bueno ya que tengo la ecuación cuadrática sabemos que podemos identificar el vértice si hacemos
"x" - "b" igual a 0 ,es decir sólo lo que está dentro del cuadrado.
Si hacemos "x" - b igual a 0, voy a obtener que "x" igual a "b" es el valor de "x" del punto del vértice
y por lo tanto,
todo esto me quedaría que es 0 y entonces me queda que "y" es igual a "c" y este es mi valor de "y"
del punto del vértice. Así que vamos a hacerlo, vamos a tomar esta ecuación.
Déjame escribirla aquí abajo y voy a intentar escribir la de la forma canónica. Lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta es que esta
ecuación es completamente divisible entre -3, alguien nos puso la trampa de que esto se puede dividir
completamente entre - 3 y entonces si sacó como un factor común al - 3 voy a obtener aa
y me quedaría mucho mejor tener en lugar de -3x cuadrada
simple y sencillamente tener "x" cuadrada, por lo tanto voy a factorizar el -3 y me va a quedar -3 que multiplica a "x"
cuadrada -8x  24 entre -3 me da -8 -8x más
9 -27 entre -39 y esto bueno, espera espera voy a escribir aquí el 9 hasta acá,
por que voy a completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto más 9 y entonces ya tengo esta ecuación cuadrática.
Al menos ya tengo el valor de "a" y ahora lo que voy a hacer es sacar el binomio al cuadrado perfecto.
Para esto me fijo en el coeficiente que tiene la "x" de la primera potencia
que es -8, este -8 recuerda que hay que dividirlo entre 2 y después
elevarlo al cuadrado, por lo tanto me queda -8 entre 2 es -4, al cuadrado me da 16, entonces le estoy agregando 16
y date cuenta que con esto ya obtengo el binomio al cuadrado perfecto.
Esto es lo mismo que "x" -4 elevado al cuadrado pero, esta ecuación al agregarle 16 se desbalancea.
Si yo lo que quiero es balancearla de nuevo, lo que tengo que hacer es
quitarle 16 para que 16 -16 me dé 0.
Esto está desbalanceado y recuerda que además estoy multiplicando por el -3 y entonces me va a quedar, que la primera parte de esta ecuación que
tengo aquí "x" cuadrada -8x más 16 esto es lo mismo que "x" -4 al cuadrado.
Ya tengo mi binomio al cuadrado perfecto,
entonces qué me va a quedar, si todo esto que estoy poniendo de morado es mi binomio cuadrado perfecto,
si te das cuenta que ya tengo el cuadrado del primero -2 veces el primero por el segundo, más el cuadrado del segundo que
fue lo que aumente pero, además quité -16 por lo tanto no le pasó nada raro a mi ecuación y esto sigue equilibrado.
Entonces me quedan -3 que multiplica a "x" -4 elevado al cuadrado,
recuerda que esto salió de "x" cuadrada -8x más 16 y después tengo -16 más 9 lo cual me da -7.
Esto es mi ecuación cuadrática y ya casi lo tengo de la forma canónica si te das cuenta,
tenemos -3 que multiplica a un paréntesis pero, también me falta
distribuir este - 3 para obtener
perfectamente mi forma canónica, y me va a quedar.
Eso se queda igual y después me queda -3 por -7 lo cual es más 21
y ya obtuve mi forma canónica de esta ecuación cuadrática. Ahora lo que me pide es que además
identifica el vértice y para identificar el vértice recuerda que la parte de adentro de mi binomio al cuadrado, la tengo que hacer igual a 0,
es decir tengo que tomarme "x" -4 igual a 0. Voy a escribirlo y de aquí obtengo que "x" es igual a 4.
"x" es igual a 4
y entonces si esto se hace 0
esto de aquí se va a ser 0 y ya me va a quedar que es igual a 21, "y" es igual a 21
"x" es igual a 4 y entonces este es el punto de mi vértice
de esta ecuación cuadrática. A ver vamos a graficarla. Tengo aquí me eje de las "y",
este va a ser mi eje de las "y", me voy a tomar por aquí a mi eje de las "x",
y mi vértice está cuando "x" vale 4 voy a suponer que esta es cuatro
"y" vale 21, voy a suponer que este es el valor de "y" igual a 21
xy y entonces aquí tengo el punto de mi vértice, ahora la pregunta es
¿Esta parábola abre hacia abajo o abre hacia arriba? Es decir va hacia arriba o va hacia abajo, y ¿Cómo lo puedo saber?
bueno lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta, es que esta parte que tengo aquí esto de aquí, es siempre
positivo por que tengo una expresión elevada al cuadrado.
Recuerda que todo lo que elevó al cuadrado siempre es positivo o es mayor o igual que 0,
y a una cosa mayor o igual que 0 si la multiplicó por un número negativo es decir por - 3,
voy a obtener que todo esto que tengo aquí siempre me va a dar valores negativos por que un positivo por un negativo,
siempre me da un negativo, es decir
un valor menor o igual a 0, y si a esto le sumó 21 quiere decir varias cosas.
Primero que el valor más grande que puede tener esta parábola,
es cuando esta parte de rojo es igual a 0, cuando esta parte de rojo es igual a 0 me queda mi
vértice, es decir mi máximo y a partir de aquí le voy a ir quitando,
y restando cosas a 21, por que sí a 21 le agrego algo negativo, se va a hacer cada vez más pequeño y entonces la parábola tiene
que abrir hacia abajo, por que estoy obteniendo valores cada vez más pequeños.
Esto quiere decir que mi
parábola va hacia abajo, o abre hacia abajo. Es de esta forma, voy a intentar  dibujarla lo mejor posible y va a ser algo
así. Esta es mi parábola o el esboso de mi parábola de esta ecuación cuadrática. Y date cuenta que esto siempre pasa
por que aquí al lado tenemos un número negativo, tenemos el - 3, si tuviésemos un número positivo entonces esta parábola
abriría hacia arriba. El valor de "a" es el que me indica si abre hacia arriba o hacia abajo mi parábola.
Entonces este vértice es un máximo por que el valor de "a" es negativo, si el valor de "a" fuera positivo entonces mi parábola abriría
hacia arriba y el vértice sería un mínimo.